if you're a lead foot you should know
there are ways to mitigate some of the
expenses associated with a speeding
ticket that is the topic in today's la
vegas now segment with eric palacios
eric all of us at one point or another
it seems like most of us
have gotten a traffic ticket what do
most people do
when they get a speeding ticket
most people will simply pay it they'll
either
send it in or call and uh
and give their payment information and
think this is the best and
quickest way to take care of a ticket
what should they do
because that's different right what they
do and what they should do is is very
different a lot of people don't realize
that by simply paying the ticket
in most cases you're admitting guilt
which means that
this is going to stay in your permanent
record you're going to get points on
your license
your insurance company is going to find
out about it and most likely
your insurance rates will go up on top
of this you might have to pay
stiff fines and also attend traffic
school
which is not too costly but it can take
hours of your time
yeah i've been through traffic school
it's not the most exciting
moments of my life i will say that so
uh there's a way to uh there's a process
you guys have that can take care of that
right
yes rather than spending uh hours in
line to get into the courthouse and to
wait to
talk to the judge you can have an
attorney take care of it and we can do
this for you
we go to court uh we talk to the judge
or to the district attorney and
get it uh usually dismissed if not
dismissed we can get the charges reduced
to a parking ticket
which means it doesn't go on your record
it doesn't affect points on your license
your insurance rates won't go up in most
instances you won't have to go to
traffic school
it just simply goes away normally you
still have to pay a fine
but in the long run it's a lot more
advantageous to have us take care of it
for you
and it's relatively inexpensive right
especially compared to those
increased insurance rates exactly most
people think well if i'm going to hire
an attorney it's going to cost me
hundreds of thousands of dollars but a
ticket is much different we can take
care of most citations for 125 dollars
sometimes less
yeah and that's that's not much money
compared to
what you could be paying in the long run
that's it and you're saving yourself the
hassle if you give us a call on tuesdays
we have what's called ticket tuesdays
uh where we only charge 50 to take care
of your traffic tickets so it's a great
deal
we take care of all the headaches and
the hassle we do it all
you simply get a letter from us in a few
months saying we've gone to court we got
your ticket dismissed or we got your
ticket reduced to a parking ticket
uh here's the fine and here's where you
have to send a payment sounds like a
great option
eric thanks so much always appreciate it
great uh seeing you again and we'll see
you soon all right take care
if you want more information you can
give eric palacios and associates a call
that phone number 702-444-7777
las vegas now will be right